all right we are excited about our next
guest actor director and writer Lake
Bell she is known for a 2013 film in the
world that won best screenplay at the
Sundance Film Festival it's all about a
vocal coach who wants to do voice-overs
for movie trailers Bale continues to
explore our voices in our new audiobook
inside voice my obsession with how we
sound she speaks with several people
that have iconic voices including Jeff
Goldblum since yesman Andrew Barrymore
take a listen to Drew
I don't know if this is the same for
anyone else I don't know the sound of my
own voice can anyone know the sound of
their own voice can they actually
audibly scientifically hear themselves
so I get what everybody's talking about
because there's a consistency and theme
of The Voice but I don't know what my
voice sounds like
first on CBS mornings Lake Bill joins us
right now how are you doing thanks for
having me of course I just want to say
with my kids I do switch which but do
you know about that all the Halloween
candy and then you switch it out it's
like a payment kind of like yeah with
the Tariff thing I like that so anyway
if you do that with the resting witch
face
I love the audiobook thank you because
it starts off
um very comically and we get to hear
different
um times when you were using your voice
and you're quite embarrassed but you
have fun with it so when did your
obsession start about how your voice
sounds I've been categorically obsessed
with the human voice from a very young
age I think it was a great
procrastination tool when I was a kid it
was like okay like it's time to go to
bed and then I'd be like but what about
some wild voices you know and so then it
made adults laugh which then meant I
didn't have to go to bed and then when
you make adults laugh it's very
indelible I think that's it makes that's
the key but that's the thing like number
one I've known you but I didn't know
that what you can do with your voice I'm
like Nate I said I'm just going to
listen to one episode I ended up
listening to all five because your
poison ivy HBO let's hear
um okay well poison ivy I have to just
be very clear I use my own voice to to
create a lot of characters so it's
really poison ivy she's very naughty
yeah there's just a lot of little
colorful you know what I'm saying Cheryl
with the southern accent
um Cheryl is more like this and she's
Cheryl
um but then when I the one I'm most
proud of is um being the omniscient
voice of the Apple iPhone
let's hear it which again but Gail it's
not like you know it's gonna sound like
me but it's like Apple iPhone 6s you
know it's like sultry it's sultry but
it's like me with a Sprinkle of sultry
you know what I mean it's not far off
but like this is something I never
thought about because I'm like Drew I
never thought about my voice either but
you said we pay attention to other
things in our life we don't pay
attention to our voices and we should
why I think our voice we don't realize
it's a road map of everything we've
endured it's traumas whether you you
smoked a lot in your 20s you can hear it
you know maybe you had a step parent who
emulated a certain sound like Howard
Hughes or maybe you lived in three
different burrows when you're growing up
it it really is kind of this incredible
tapestry of everywhere you've been you
know so so well said I agree completely
it's amazing yeah where are you from uh
from Maryland Florida okay and it
definitely comes out in the way I say
water forward with no R usually it's the
it's the vowel sounds but what's cool
about it is that we're it's so pliable
the voice is like in constant state of
evolution you know and even with your
jobs as like being in the news media how
you sound when you've had you know know
maybe a couple drinks or you're chilling
or whatever it is right you're gonna
you're gonna style shift a little bit
right I wanna I wanna fact check you out
a little bit here you've never thought
about your voice you are a professional
broadcaster you are but I haven't it's
not but what about like let's make it
works better right now yes thank you
when you first started do you feel like
it no I didn't think about it you know
what that's okay you know what I'm so
happy to have okay great I'm glad you
brought it this is such a setup I see
okay could you please roll this let's
roll this out please
radio listener there's probably no
stranger on 5 30 he's as reliable as
Clockwork and has been for decades but
as Channel 3's Linda so okay so does
that girl still have a job you look
incredible I always say is it's a little
bit pitched up right so usually after
you know as we grow up I mean I've had
two kids so my my voice has hormonally
changed after but you know what like
what's so interesting about that is I
actually thought I sounded good you
listened to it there and I I cringe when
I hear that why why do Ukraine because
it does sound very high pitched it
doesn't sound very professional
in it you know local news cases it'll
sound like you you do something but you
were saying sometimes that you actually
lower your voice because if you look I
thought this was interesting on your
tapes yeah if people lower their voice
it does make themselves sound more
authoritative well incredible I mean
that's right that's up for discussion
and for argument but it I find that I do
lower my voice a bit when I want in this
setting certainly right I want you to
take me seriously I want you to listen
to my words I want to wield some kind of
authority right and so I do find myself
leaning a little bit heavier on that as
opposed to the sexy baby voice which I
find yes for a lot of people I knew it
would come up what's the sexy baby boys
like look
all I'll say is
it's something that I really am proud of
and it's and it's not it doesn't evoke
that you're less than or you're like not
smart but it is up talk and it's fried
and it's pets but the thing that this is
what I thought was interesting in your
tape you said everybody should say the
words and I actually did this
authoritative
marzipan yes and why should we say that
phrase well look I'm a voice nerd okay I
really like the sound of people's voices
and when you say authoritative marzipan
it's hitting so many different vowels
and shapes and consonants that in any
accent and dialect it always Garners a
delightful result I thought I heard
Chris Rock on that what's his voice like
uh he's I hear it's pretty good
it's very distinct
thank you so much inside voices
you are delightful in the book you are
so good like so good